what's up everybody hey it's cameron
with motion science
and uh who's here today who's here today
where are you dialing in from what part
of the world are you dialing in from
how are you guys doing on this fine day
it's a little bit chilly here in florida
which is i got my sweatshirt on it's not
actually that cold but it's like you
know 72 degrees which when you live in
florida starts to feel kind of chilly
which is funny to say
uh hey for those that don't know me
my name is cameron i've been a motion
designer for 20 years over 20 years
actually
started in
1999
just kind of playing around with it
primarily after effects cinema 4d and
for 13 years i was a remote freelancer
before fruit remote freelancing was even
a thing i had opportunity opportunity to
work with a lot of big clients uh and
agencies and studios and post-production
houses throughout my career
so i'm still very lucky in that sense um
so that's a little bit about me
uh but hey i wanna know uh who's here
and uh where you're at we got uh we got
busy
i'm getting better at name pronunciation
so i've learned i'm getting better at
name pronunciation so that's awesome
uh awesome for me right uh so hi busy
bc
probably getting this one wrong uh matt
what's going on hey matt
good to have you here
anda hey anda good to see you again
hey from transylvania that's awesome
transylvania never been there would be
amazing to visit
it's winter time there wow
it's winter here too but it's just
florida it's just warm in the winter
time so i'm pretty lucky there that's
why i moved to florida
uh busy's from nigeria okay awesome
never been to nigeria either i love to
travel
brandon what's up brandon
good to have your brandon thanks for
being here and robbie
i want to say robbie
if it's rob please let me know good
vibes good vibes only awesome awesome
uh let me know what else is here today
but um i also am going to tell you guys
we're going to talk about um
three motion designer hacks to save you
time
three motion designers hacks to save you
time before i get into it i'm going to
show you some screen sharing here
i do want to know from you
do you have any motion design hacks that
you like to use in your workflows
do you have any motion design hacks you
like to use in your workflows you don't
have to get
tell me in the chat box please you don't
have to get very specific like oh i hold
down control and shift and i do this but
i'd like to hear like an overall general
statement from you if you have it
about what your favorite hacks are um
and maybe that's hard to do i know with
after effects when people ask me
questions like how do you do that i'm
like okay i have to hold down this this
and this and i click this and so it can
be kind of
challenging to say what your hacks are
but i would love to hear
if you have any favorite hacks
um what they are
in motion design what are your favorite
hacks
um
robbie i got it robbie awesome okay cool
good to know i pronounced it right i'm
getting better as i said robby you got
any motion designer hacks you like to
use
and you know a hack is anything that
just saves you time right it can be just
something very simple which is what i'm
going to show you today i'll show you a
couple of simple things and
something that's a little bit more
complex
while you're answering that in the chat
box though
i want to let you know i have a free
workshop over at motion science dot tv
slash
workshop
and i actually i need to make a little
graphic that comes across my screen i'm
thinking about that motion science dot
tv slash workshop motion science dot tv
backslash workshop
i'm going to show you in this free
workshop seven secrets to cinematic
motion design
i've got seven tips tricks and concepts
here behind pro level motion design
plus i give you access to a very special
offer
at the very end of it that you won't
find anywhere else for for staying
around and watching the workshop
so please check it out if you haven't
already done so it's a powerful powerful
workshop that
i'm really proud of and it's very well
put together
and
it's got a lot of great information in
it
um
okay so robbie back to our hacks here
robbie says i'm always making a control
layer shape layer in which i put all my
colors and sliders interesting
wow that's awesome
that's one of those hacks that i need to
probably
do a little bit more for myself and my
own workflow i know what you're talking
about robbie
and when you're using lots of colors
and things like that it's easy to
reference
and really change colors quickly so
amazing hack thank you for sharing
robbie
uh roz from dallas hey roz from dallas
good to have you here
good to have you here i love dallas
jonas
hi jonas
lloyd what's going on lloyd
happy to have you here lloyd lloyd's a
long time motion science
uh student
robby also has a
branding comp in which i put logos
elements and precomp so i know which
elements i got for my client that's
awesome too robbie wow
i have never heard of a hack like that
anything to speed up your workflow right
a branding comp which i put logos
elements and precomp so i know which
albums i got from my client that's
awesome
yeah mark says broad that's a great idea
i totally agree
on the effects console for adding
effects just press command plus space
and type the effect saves me time and
space on screen honda i know so many
people who use um
effects console
and absolutely love it i don't know
anyone who doesn't like it
and it's funny i don't have it i've
never used it i try to stay away from it
for when i teach
courses and lessons so that people don't
have it they're wondering what what is
that but yeah amazing hack
raz
says use templates from envato as a
starting point that's a great hack as
well it's a great hack to use for i
found it very useful for my corporate
clients when i didn't have to get as
creative
envato elements have gotten so creative
though over the years
i stopped using them a couple years ago
just because i actually have still have
a subscription to them though so i would
highly recommend envato elements
but yeah it's a great starting point you
can save yourself hours and hours and
hours
just having those templates to start
from i also like to take multiple
templates and bash them together that's
what i call it bashing
where i take an element from this
template and an element from this
template and maybe from this one and put
them together and make something new
saves you a ton of time you know and
templates are pretty relatively cheap
depending on the template
um so when you look at what they're
gonna let's say they're gonna cost you
20 30 40
maybe even 50. um it's still going to
save you time based on your hourly rate
right
what might take you an entire day to do
an entire you know 10
hours or something or eight hours you
can bash together with templates for
100 bucks or less
in just a couple hours
great hack uh blacksmooth alessandra
what's going on long time
motion science student as well as moe
murdoch what is going on yo yo mo
good to have you here
brandon says the effects console again
yup
that's a hack i would say it's a total
hack
also i use the time remapper to put
elements inside so i can place and move
them around without going into nesting
comps hmm
now that one i don't so i use time
remapper to put elements inside so i can
place and move them around without going
into nesting cops i'm not familiar with
that hack
so i'm gonna have to look that one up
but it sounds like a good one
uh every time i see you have even longer
hair
well i'm growing my hair out so
i started growing it out last march
it's funny i finished recording the new
stylecraft in
late february i think it was or early
march and then i started growing my hair
out
so anyone who's in stylecraft who sees
me in those lessons
[Music]
i've got really really short hair like i
was shaving my hair short not shaving it
but really short and now it's growing
longer
actually marker remap okay
now now i understand a little bit better
uh laurent good times hd what's going on
lauren all is good here you've had some
amazing work in the community
lately over at starcraft
i've just seen it i haven't commented on
it i've just glanced at it but i will be
taking a look at it very soon
mark i try to leave the layer position
keyframes untouched so i can always move
layers around whenever
yeah if you can do that that's a good
good hack
i'm a fan of less key frames is more and
it's easier to control so like when you
get a layer that has
so many keyframes very challenging
to move things around
one hack you can
do um and i just thought of this and
maybe i'll show this in a future lesson
is
you can actually you know drag with your
cursor over those keyframes and
highlight all those keyframes and then
you can move
things in groups with keyframes and they
all move together
so
great great hack mark thank you
okay
these are some awesome hacks if anyone
has any more hacks as i'm going through
this i will definitely come back at the
end here and uh read through your hack
and
put up here on screen so thanks everyone
so far who has shared their hack i
really appreciate it
i'm going to
dive into
my
see here
okay so my first hack here is a pretty
basic one and a lot of you are probably
gonna know this one but there are some
people who aren't gonna know it
um that is a hack where you can easily
replace your layer and after effects
very quickly
so you're gonna see here
i've got a comp here this is a project
from stylecraft and what we're going to
focus on is we're going to focus on this
film textures dirt layer here
and you can see what it is it's these
kind of splotches that pop up here on
the side at the bottom
if i solo this
you can see right there this is the
layer that we're kind of messing around
with and let's say let's say the client
doesn't like this layer
maybe they want more
maybe they want less
um
so there's an easy way that we can
replace this layer within our
composition
uh without having to drag and drop
more layers and kind of reposition them
and all that good stuff so what all we
have to do is i'm going to right click
on that layer and i'm going to say
reveal
layer source and project and it's going
to open up my project here in my folder
structure
and you're going to see we're using film
textures dirt 2. this is from film
textures by
motion science by the way
and we're using dirt too and you can see
how it looks here now what i can do is i
can try any other film textures dirt
here by just clicking on that layer
holding down alt or option and you can
see i have a little plus sign there
and i can go down to the layer i want to
replace with that plus sign
and just
let go and it replaces that layer
instantly and you can see now we have a
different look here we've got like
bigger
dirt
that's on screen
maybe that works maybe it doesn't maybe
i want to try texture three so i'm going
to click hold down alt option
come down here and just release
and it's going to replace
this layer and with film textures dirt
three which we get a totally different
look
right
and i can try maybe i can try four
so
alt option
let go
there we go
i like that one a lot you know it's kind
of busy
a little busy but it looks pretty good
we could also try
film texture dirt 5.
wow that one's really busy right
it's a lot going on with that one so
maybe we go back
i think i liked one or three
it's just an easy way a quick way
c3 is going to work for me it's just a
quick and easy way to
replace layers and to see how things
look
now we can do this with any type of
layer
except for text i don't think we can use
it for text layers
um text that's just native inside of
after effects i mean you know if you
create a text layer here it doesn't
create that layer up in the project
window
so it's not possible with that but like
let's say we want to replace the logo
right so we're using the twilight zone
logo so i can right click and say reveal
the source and project
excuse me
and we're using the toilet zone but
maybe for whatever reason
this show needs to be called eclipse
right and this is just an eclipse logo
from i think the movie eclipse and it's
a vector layer it's an illustrator layer
again i'm just going to click it alt or
option on my keyboard
hold down
release
and now it's going to have to you know
preview itself again
and my software is checking for an
update
which that's always so annoying
but you can see
again the logo which used to say
twilight zone is now instantly replaced
with this eclipse logo this vector layer
and i can see okay instantly
here's logo one versus logo two
and if i could go to preview it'd be
okay
there we go
um and i saw that bissy just asked does
this work for a composition yes
uh so you could um i don't have any
pre-comps i don't think in here
let's look yeah no pre-comps within this
project or within
this one but if we had um
i'm gonna probably screw things up here
but
let's just try this so if we took
these four layers and let's say we
pre-composed them
and this is just called um let's call it
type
and we're gonna have to
[Music]
yeah it's not gonna work because the
transfer modes here
actually i probably should hold on here
on the spot i'll get it though
select all of these
okay pre-compose
call it type
and we'll make sure it's 3d we'll
collapse it
and then like let's say for whatever
reason
um i just have to create another
i don't even know what this is
reveal their source and project so
here's a composition of texture and you
can see if i select type here
and hold down alt alt option and bring
it down
it does replace it right it's in the
same 3d position everything now this
looks horrible because i replaced it
with a texture but yeah you can replace
with comps
um
you know vector files raster files like
jpegs
anything except for type like type
that's just created within after effects
if the so black smoke production says if
the layer you're replacing has keyframes
that the new one have them too yes
it does
so let's just say
uh we're just
doing some random
maybe this logo moves up
right
and i'm going to preview again which
will will solo this one
now there's a texture below it which is
using an alpha matte which is why it's
cutting off here
but um yeah i could replace this with
eclipse now
and it's still going to be the same
you know frames p position there's my
keyframes there so yeah
it's a very powerful time saving hack
that um
i use it
you know and every time i work in after
effects
that's what i got replace layer alt
option click and drag
okay next let's go into um
this one's a little bit more advanced
okay and i'm gonna go ahead and delete
what i have here
and let's go into one view
and what we have here is um a 3d floor
which we have here i'll unlock that
we've got a floor it's just a solid
layer
and
it's got a checkerboard effect applied
to it so it's just a 3d floor and i have
the checkerboard so you can see a little
bit better and then we have lights which
is a 3d
layer of text
and it's just sitting on this floor here
right
and we have a camera
and the camera you can see it's just a
3d camera so i can move around my scene
i can look at it and
all that good stuff so
i want to add a 3d light to the scene
and a lot of times it can be very
challenging
to control 3d lights in after effects
especially spotlights so we're going to
layer new and we're going to go to light
and we're gonna have the spotlight and
color is fine intensity is fine
cast shadow is yes and
yada yada okay great
so there's our light and
you can see i can move this light
i can you know drag it up and it's it's
casting shadows back here
um but if i wanted to get you know a
little bit further back
you can see i'm already having kind of
issues with like
adjusting the z position there we go z
now it's off the screen
and it's getting more and more
challenging to control this light right
it's very challenging to control light
so this is my hack for you so whenever
you're using a spotlight specifically
you could use this with other lights but
this works really with spotlights
what we're going to do is create a new
3d camera
and we're going to call this the we'll
call it the light camera
and we need to make sure that this is a
two node camera now a lot of times if
you follow any you know a lot of my
lessons i always use onenote cameras but
for this we need a two node camera and
i'll show you why click ok
the reason we need a two node camera is
because
we're going to parent this camera to
this light and a spotlight under
transform uses a point of interest and
it uses position okay
whereas a two node camera also uses that
it has a point of interest and position
so
right now we're looking through the
light camera
that's fine and dandy if i turn it off
you can see we immediately go back
to our other 3d camera camera one and
that's because this scene is set to
active camera now if i was to change it
to light camera we're always looking
through the light camera if we change it
to camera one we're always looking
through camera one
by default after effects is active
camera that's how i like to work
so i'm gonna turn light camera back on
so that's our default camera now
and what we're going to do is we're
going to
use an expression to parent our point of
interest to our light camera so all we
have to do is hold down alt or option
and click on point of interest
and then with this expression
highlighted we're going to drag our
pickwick pick whip up here to point of
interest and just click outside that box
and then we're going to alter option
click on position
drag this pick whip up to position of
the light camera again
and then click outside the box now again
nothing looks different right it looks
exactly how it looked before
but the difference is now that our our
light can our spotlight is actually
looking through the camera so now all we
have to do with our light camera
selected
is use our camera tools
to move
our our um
our camera which essentially is moving
our light as well
now to explain this to show this a
little better i'm going to switch to two
views
and i've got
in my first view here i've got um
open this up
i'm going to have this be our
camera one
so there's our original camera and in
this view i want it to be the light
camera okay
so now as i'm
watch over here on this side you're
gonna see you're gonna see the shadows
moving on the floor as i'm positioning
our light camera
like so so you can see there see those
shadows moving on the right side
so this is a really awesome way to like
really hone in to kind of
get that that light to be that spotlight
to be exactly where we want it to be
right look at those lights see the
shadows moving over here
so this
view on the right is what our main
camera is seeing this is what's going to
render out what we're seeing on the left
is just a viewport of our light camera
so that we can position our spotlight
exactly how we want it to be
so i could turn up the brightness of it
i wanted to here
because it is pretty dark on this side
but all i have to do is just make sure
i'm selected on the light camera
and just move around
until i get it just how i want it lit
i could even go in really tight like
that if i wanted to
so there you go that's my simple trick
for using a 3d camera
attached to your spotlight to light your
scene
and then here in the final hack for
these three hacks i'm going to show you
today
um this is a new project hack
and how this works is you may have
noticed that as i was working on that
first project
i've got this folder structure here okay
and
in output i've got the comps one two
three there's three columns like we see
down here
we've got a comps folder with precomps
and working comps we also have an assets
folder we have ae imports
which has a project imported into it
which i have here
we have audio if we had audio in our
project and edit
footage
for pre-renders proxies stock footage
these are all empty right now we've got
a raster folder
for things like jpegs pngs photoshop
files
solids
and we have a vector folder as well
that if you look at the imported project
i brought into brought into this project
um you're gonna see a little bit more
like how like there's so many elements
inside of these folder structures
um
it makes things way more organized right
for your projects and there's a way
that you can make it so that every time
you open up a new project
like we're gonna do here go ahead and
save this one
you can see i instantly have my folder
structure here
right so now i can start importing
assets and putting different assets
different elements within these folders
by default when you open up a new after
effects project it's just blank there's
nothing there there's no folder
structure nothing and you know you can
go through and you can create all the
folders but it takes a lot of time to do
that
so what i've done is
i created a i started a new project okay
and within this project i created these
folders so
you just go down here and you click on
this little create a new folder icon and
um
i don't know what could we add here
that's missing
um
how about music i would probably put
music
inside of audio obviously so i'm going
to drag music into audio there we go and
maybe we'll do another folder inside
there called like uh vo okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
set up a project here in after effects
exactly how i want it to be
i'm also going to create a composition
which i happen to call output it can be
called anything you want it could be
called like render
you know whatever and i create a
composition that's typically
you know how
i like to start my my composition so i
like to work at 24 frames a second so i
make this front this composition 24
frames a second
1920 by 1080 is a typical size for what
i'm working at if you're working at a
different size or different frame rate
you would change that here
um and then 10 seconds
is a nice starting point um it's
actually pretty long
for a composition
on a lot of projects i would work on a
lot of times i would work on uh shots
that were you know five seconds or
shorter
um but for ten seconds great it works
and what you're going to do is you're
going to set up a new project just like
this you can even create multiple
compositions here if you want
precomps you could put one in there
working comps that kind of stuff you set
up your folder structure exactly how you
want it to be okay and then what you're
going to do is you're going to save that
project out wherever you want to save it
you're going to save that project out on
a hard drive okay
wherever you want it to be
once that project's saved you're going
to come back
into your preferences here in after
effects and under preferences if we go
down a little ways you're going to see
one here called new project
we're going to click on that one
open it up
and
by default this is not turned on okay so
it's off you're going to turn this on
and then you're going to select choose
project template and when you select
this it's going to take you say where
where is your project where's the one
that you just saved out
you're going to
find that place
wherever that project is you're going to
select it
and then that's basically all you have
to do
click ok
and now every time you open up a new
project
i'm not going to save this one it's
going to open up that project exactly
how you wanted it set up with that
folder structure
so um you could even save assets within
this if you wanted to
however you want your projects to always
start up this is how it's going to
happen
like i said new project
this is off by default
so when i start up a new project
you can see it everything's blank
there's no composition here there's
nothing in my project folder
you know you have to start over from
scratch every single time
i would highly advise that you make a
project
template that is how you like to start
your projects turn that on and now every
time you create a new project boom
you've got your composition there you've
got your folder structure you are good
to go
okay so there you go my friends that is
uh three motion designer hacks that um i
absolutely love that i use all the time
in my workflows
um there's a lot of hacks out there um
these are just three that i just wanted
to pull to show you immediately that i
know could save you some time so
what did you guys think did you like
those hacks
are these are any of these hacks ones
that um you have used before or that you
use in your workflow that saves you time
as well i'd love to hear from you i'm
going to look at the comments here i've
got
a guy outside my window blowing the
grass as i'm recording as i'm live here
so you can probably hear that hopefully
not too bad
let's see here
[Music]
uh alessandro's recently started using
animation composer for the moma project
it saves me a lot of time so he's
referring to a moment project within um
the original stylecraft
but animation composer is a huge huge
time saver i think i talked about that
on a live idea like my three favorite
effects
a couple weeks ago
i absolutely love animation composer
uh robbie if you put a transform effect
on an adjustment layer you can animate
everything beneath it scale position etc
yeah that's an amazing hack
yes
transformer effect you know i didn't use
the transformer effect until
several years ago like for all these
years i didn't use it didn't understand
what it was for
that's one of the big
things you can use transform for
effects controls for sure yep
blender versus cinema 4d yeah that's i
mean i don't know if that's a hack per
se that's a software choice
but uh if you're faster in blender then
sure
i'll just read through some of his
comments
uh robby a bit related if you hold down
swift uh when you pick whip maybe shift
when you pick with the layer to know
when it takes over all the transform
scale settings yes it does you actually
don't have to do that on this hack
uh because it um
aligns position and uh point of interest
immediately but yeah that's one i use a
lot too
uh shift parent is a big one
uh hello abby
this is like you like said before do you
use selected camera yep mm-hmm
yeah i'm gonna show a cinema 4d hack
uh one of these one of these weeks too
that's very similar to this
yep from perspective light camera the
shadows are always 100 behind the object
yes which is why i use a two view camera
mode setup at all times so i can see if
you're just looking through the light
camera it looks like the light is always
behind the text
like mark's saying and it's very uh it's
confusing it's visually confusing but if
you have that viewport set up and you
have the uh the right viewport set up
then you're good to go
yes brandon you can create multiple
light cameras which really changes the
game absolutely
uh
graph graphene can we import after
effects projects into a new yes of
course
uh that's what i did in this original
project so or the original example i
showed you
so what i have here actually let me open
it back up here
recent
so if you go into ae imports
um
this is a another project that i
imported into my i created a project
called uh three hacks project just to
show you guys these hacks and i had set
up three compositions
a replace layer ae lights and a new
project and then what i did was for the
replace layer project i was trying to
give a good example to show you so i
imported uh this style frame finishing
project from stylecraft
and you're able to just import it right
in
um just by selecting the aep file and
when you bring in that aep file it's
going to bring in everything
uh how you have it set up within that
project so it's going to bring in the
folder structure i had set up in that
project with everything inside of here
uh it's amazing it's a it's a huge time
saver this is like we were talking
earlier about hacking
uh projects like from envato elements
taking like templates and bashing them
together this is exactly what i do i
import like two to three
uh projects after effects aep files into
one
after effects file
project and then i just combine them all
together so i have three imported in i
can start combining elements and doing
all that
appreciate it jw thank you
yeah mo uses that all the time
awesome
lauren uses the
alt drag
and the project template
awesome
i knew about one but two and three are
awesome okay awesome mark awesome
yeah sean
learned the motion science uh tip before
from uh
one of the interviews yeah i've got this
video out there somewhere it's one of
the
one of the earlier uh videos i made i
believe
i've been used i've used replace layers
for 3d camera tracking solves yeah it's
a great way to use it too yeah when you
camera track
footage it creates solid layers and
within that that plug-in you can create
solids and you can replace those solids
with vector layers raster images text
whatever it is
great great hack
honda's using all three hacks
uh and then brandon says any road
scoping hacks for objects that are
similar colors and shapes with different
depths currently going frame by frame
and it's uh i bet it's ugg
um gosh
who likes to rotoscope not me
similar colors and shapes with different
depths
um i mean off the top of my
head
you could try
um
like making the image black and white
and with that black and white using
levels and crushing the whites and
blacks and maybe it will separate
the objects it's hard to know without
seeing the project
but really crushing the color or even
keeping it colored and crushing the
colors so that there's less there's more
contrast between the objects right
but for similar colors that's going to
be challenging
uh a depth map that pulls it out so i
saw the new a new script on aescripts
where it's a depth map extractor it came
out last week
it looks really awesome it uses ai
i can't remember what it's called if you
go to their main page you're going to
see it's like their newest script their
newest plugin
it pulls depth maps out mats out of
footage and it looks i've never tried it
looks great though
and if not maybe you have to do it frame
by frame i mean before rotos before the
roto brush tool that's what we did frame
by frame
yeah
uh
that's what alanda is saying lawrence
got a great tip there colorama effect
uh the plug-in is only for windows okay
maybe try the colorama effect
or just crushing
and creating more contrast
that's what i would suggest so
um jw says mocha
all right guys that's gonna do it for
this um motion science live uh thank you
so much for being here today i really
appreciate it and i'll be back next week
and i do plan on doing some more motion
designer hacks
uh soon so within the next few weeks or
so so i have a lot of them so just want
to start off with three basic ones
and uh
we'll move on to some other ones
in future videos so
thank you everyone for being here today
uh like i said if you haven't seen my
free workshop check it out
motionscience.tv
workshop check it out it's awesome uh
i'm just gonna wrap it up for you guys
have an amazing rest of your week and
hope to see you guys all next uh tuesday
1 p.m eastern time until then keep on
creating